before we solve a problem we should ask
has it been solved anywhere in the
natural world
life has ingenious ways of meeting its
needs in the Namib Desert there's very
little groundwater but there is a fog
that comes in a few times a week and
there's a tiny black beetle it climbs up
to the top of a dune stands on his head
lifts his wing scales up into that flow
and on these wing scales there are bumps
the tips of the bumps are like magnets
for water the sides of the bumps are
waxy so fog comes in begins to aggregate
on the tips the water runs down the
trough and into the critters mouth this
is being mimicked now in fog catching
Nets that are 10 times better than the
fog catching Nets we currently have in
fact there's a company that is putting
this surface on the inside of water
bottles to create a self filling water
bottle water is the new oil
it's what nations will be fighting over
unfortunately being able to pull water
out of air that's what I'm more exciting
biomimetic areas for more episodes of
things like a tree subscribe to the
wired Channel